dear Apple you guys are a great company
everything you have great relationship
with your customers already you guys
have tons of money you know we got a
great system going on we give you money
you give us great stuff people love you
it's wonderful and it's obvious that
lots of people already know about you so
you're doing a good job that's obvious
but there are just a few things suck
here's one question for example are you
guys patent troll steer Apple you know
how are your computers are all white and
shiny and beautiful and silver aluminum
kind of style that's nice and everything
but why don't you guys make some black
computers remember the black MacBook
remember how well that did remember how
most people like that imagine a black
Mac Pro a black iMac a new black Mac
Mini that would be really freaking cool
people would love that
dear Apple what's the deal with your
mice you guys over at Apple have a long
gruesome history of awful terrible
pathetic mice not ergonomic at all not
comfortable at all just bad mice and
they finish off the line up with the
Mighty Mouse and the Magic Mouse two of
the worst mice I've ever seen from such
a big company what's going on with that
dear Apple please refresh the Mac Pro
dear Apple when you guys gonna take a
risk with iOS I mean I know that people
really like it the mantras kind of if it
ain't broke don't fix it and it's simple
and it works and everything but take a
risk sometime you know maybe it's time
for a little bit of an overhaul I mean
people have been using the iPhone since
the first generation three or four years
with the same boring OS it's gotten
stale even someone like me who's been
using iOS for about a month is bored
with it on certain devices so I might be
scared of breaking it my motto is kind
of if it ain't broke don't break it but
you can still make it better improve
upon it just something to think about
dear Apple this is something not a lot
of people know about your customer
support isn't very good your technical
support isn't very technical
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
okay I also had one other quick question
just because of what monitor I wanted to
use with it do you know what the the
maximum resolution I could get out of it
is if I could use 30-inch 2560 by 1600
monitor
[Music]
is there an adapter I could use because
I don't have a thunderbolt monitor this
is a dil 30-inch monitor still I'm still
thinking about it I'm trying to build
actually the world's fastest Mac Mini so
if the bottom line is Apple you're doing
a great job you have a great company
people love you and that's pretty
obvious keep doing what you're doing
well but there are some things certain
people are waiting for like that Mac Pro
come on now today I go if you guys agree
with me about any of the things you saw
in this video feel free to give it a
thumbs up it really does help out and if
you have anything else you'd like to see
from Apple you should probably leave
then a comment down below we can get
maybe like a list going of all the
greatest stuff Apple hasn't done yet
either way thanks for watching this
video thanks for subscribing to my
channel if you have already and I'll
talk to you guys in the next video
thanks for watching peace
[Music]
you